Oh yeah, oh yeah! Amnesia The Dark Descent, we're back, baby
God damn!
How long has it been? I got exciting news. You probably read in the title. Maybe you don't know what it means
But Amnesia. I don't know how many years has it been since it came out. Oh my god! Five years,
it must have been five years. Six years.
Damn!
This is the game that changed my life
*kiss*  (づ￣ ³￣)づ
I will forever be *kiss* ( ˘ ³˘)♥ grateful for this game
Uh, they updated it! Sorry, I keep getting sidetracked
Hard mode. They have hard mode now. Okay, so this means autosave is disabled.
So only manual saving, which cost four tinderboxes! What!? [WHAT DO YOU MEAN]
Okay, this is terrible
Sanity dropping to zero,
resulting death. That doesn't happen that often, but I think your sanity drops quicker now
Less oil and tinderboxes throughout the levels.
Monsters are faster, spot the player more easily, deal more damage and stay around for longer.
And there's no danger music when the monster is there!
Oh my god!
And if you die. If you die, you have to start over, I think
No, you can still save okay. Damn. Oh, I'm a-- damn!
They should be ultra hard mode where like if you die
You have to start over. Because I remember; the reason why I got so freaked out in the first game was cuz I did such
a good job. Like I didn't want to interact with the
monster whatsoever. I'm like, I don't know what's gonna happen when he gets me, but I'm not gonna find out. So
that tension of not knowing what would happen
was so powerful I think. I think... I don't know, man. I don't want to talk too much.
Let's just... You know what? I will talk too much
I wanted, just for the sake of
reminiscing, since we're here doing that anyway. Uh, I wanted to check out my first, my first video
Yeah, I liked my old videos back in the day. What? You got a problem with that?
"Deleted video"? (;﹏;)
What!?
"Video unavailable. This video has been removed for violating YouTube's Terms of service" What?
What, what did I?
What did I say?
Aww, this is a nice comment. I didn't realize this. So it was actually kind of controversial. That's why I wanted to show part one because
In part one
This was one of the first videos I ever made and in it I said
I said specifically, I don't want to joke around while playing this like I genuinely want to be scared
So as my channel progressed and I played horror game after horror game after horror game after horror game.
People started getting really mad at me for not,
you know taking the game seriously or like me not getting scared in the game, which is just...
It would have been dishonest for me to pretend that
I was being scared just to please what people wanted after you play in a certain amount of horror games.
You don't get scared the same way because you understand how the
mechanics work and the more you understand something the less scared you get.
That is how it is because that new the more comfortable you are with it and what's theuuh...
The fear of the unknown it's the scariest thing because that's our imagination and well, I forgot the expression.
But you understand what I'm saying, hopefully
a lot of people have me accountable for what I said in part 1
But I can honestly tell you the reason why I said that was yes
because I wanted to be scared but number two I was very
Shy and very timid and I didn't feel comfortable
Being open on camera. I just it was so weird. You have to understand that. This is in 2010
The gaming channels wasn't big back. Then at least in the same sense. It was weird to do this
It was weird to record yourself playing a video game and I just didn't feel comfortable at all
So you have this comment of me saying that's not even funny
I don't know why I did that and this guy's like saying everyone says he changed he didn't change
He just became confident and I agree
I'd really if there's one trait that I've gained from doing YouTube is just becoming more comfort comfortable with myself and
I'm really happy with that. I used to be so insecure about everything. Here's another one saying it too
That's so nice to read actually. This is making me emotional me
It's not like he's really changed so much he he says confident everyone seems to complain one then
dank memes
That's cuz I didn't know how to edit just like I was so terrible at it
So when I started adding my videos to make them more entertaining
people like what the hell man you used to do uncut but then again I would add if you watch this playthrough, I
understand that the pros and the cons
But you see here puzzles is me getting stuck on the same puzzle this entire episode
Which I guess has a charm to it but I mean I could have just cut it down
I've never faced pumped so much in my life. Look at this comment love hurts, but he's really been stupid here
Like no one likes to watch someone being stuck at a game. That's just frustrating
It's not entertaining for every any one people just get pissed off. I think since this is a hard mode
I do want to keep this uncut. I do want to keep this
somewhat reminiscent of the over the pass
Hopefully people won't hold me to
Accountable for the changes. Oh it said here. I didn't even need to go out. Okay, let's begin guys
I've been looking for a reason to replay this game for so long
I've been wanting to do it but I would like I don't really know
So when they announced it?
Forgotten
Shadow haunting me. I must hurry. My name is Daniel. I live in London
Mayfair what have I done? This is crazy don't
Focus
Genius such a brief start simple beginning
No long cutscene just just that and then you're off I love it the audio as well. It's just genius
You forget how
You're playing so many bad. Horror games. You forget how good this is a memento has been added
Follow the liquid trail and find it stores. I
Also remember this game it didn't treat you like you were an idiot as well
You actually have to figure out stuff by yourself
chair
Hello
This made all my fans cry mr. Chair, how could you
I'm so sorry. I will never interact with you again. However, this is all about the plan
It's already my sanity's love
Forgot how you check it. There you go. Yeah, no crystal clear. Why am I so slow?
This is supposed to be ours liquid, oh, oh I
Don't trust you
See just that scared me so much
If you don't know what's waiting
Algorithm for the fluence mr. Chair chair mode activate
All right, oh
Yeah, you can pull up some paintings I remember I guess we really need to look inside a
Lot of the game just had such a simple mechanic the fact that you can interact with objects and that just made it
So fun, I think that I watch some interviews with oh my god
Interviews with the developers and they were they were saying just that like it's basically a walking simulator
it's a really boring game, but the fact that you can
We really feel the insanity of the character this all of this scare that oh my god
It's still so creepy, I love it
You guys remember this story I
Don't remember it that well, I'm actually really intriguing just to see what the story actually is
I don't think I'm even trying to understand it
Okay. Clearly, we can't trust this plain
Spooky too spooky, you know what? Let's have some balls. Let's see. Oh
Yeah, our sanity I forgot this is actually bad for us
You're in the dark too long and you drop your sanity and you have to oh my god. I'm an idiot
All right, we're clear. Okay
It would be pretty embarrassing to die this old are we dead it boys
Okay
This is so fun, yeah
Hello, I'm low framerate oh oh
God it's I'm low insanity. I need to find like
Anything shower using the mechanics
Cheese that I just wasted. Oh
Yeah, that's my insanity and it's not real Felix damn this is actually harder to play I
Am
Keep forgetting what I'm gonna say what's going on. I actually think this is where I am that episode one
Okay
Maybe I should keep the episodes a lot shorter
Well more modest
she says
Oh
Yeah, we get our Lantern a good old pal
Yep
And I think there's some oil in here no we still have no oil well we have oil okay
We actually have to be conservative now, it's like the expression are we going here?
You never knew what you were gonna see me they really knew how to build up suspense man
They got a do they got to make another one they gotta make a Nisha - I need it I need it
All right, let's cry
I think we found something. I don't think I was the scare
Hello
Thank You the boldest
1839 I wish I could ask how much you remember. I don't know if there will be anything left after I consumed this drink
Oh, yeah, this our older though be afraid Daniel. I can't tell you why but know this I
choose to forget
Try to find comfort and strength in that fact. There is a purpose you are my final effort to put things right?
God willing the name Alexander of Brandenburg still invoked bitter anger in you. If not, this will sound horrible
Go to the inner sanctum find Alexander and kill him
His body is old and weak. We know that it was young and strong way to prop yourself. I'll match for you
one last thing a
Shadow is following. You great a living nightmare
Breaking down reality. I
Have tried everything and there is no way to fight back. You need to escape it as long as you can
Redeem us both Daniel descend into the darkness where Alexander waits and murder him
your former self
Daniel
young
Nice to compliment yourself, I like my old self he must
such a clever way to start a horror game because not only do you have an interesting spot, but you also
Have the fear of the unknown a shadow following me. What do you mean? What does that mean?
I have no idea, but I'm already like
Don't waste the lightning Felix they're gonna yell at you like they always do
Cuz I'm an idiot. I
need to also see
There must be no reason for this room, right
Could I be wrong?
Trail
I'm actually getting scared. This is awesome
Where am I going there?
It doesn't really make sense cuz we didn't get anything from here we just got the
Wait, what is it Matt internal? So nothing there must be something here. Oh
The lever yes, I remember there we go
Okay, there we go and France all whoo
I'm smiling the whole way through this has to be a horror game
Alexander is it inside the castle in a manner of speaking?
Dump bring the lamp. You'll bring the door finally. Have you not I don't believe I have
is it connected to the
What did you call it?
the inner sanctum
All right
My most precious chamber Daniel and it lies well beyond the refinery
In fact it lies beneath the very stone of brennenburg
(Swedish) Brennenburg, well, okay, let's go there then.
"Fabrica Eliquatoria"
Yeah, that is not where I want to go
Hey, I got an idea. I bet no one tried this one
It's tough and plain it can't be torn up by hand or tools
Fine I'll be back mr. Gu
That was not very tasty
Uh-huh
All right. I think I need my penis to do that, but I don't want to use straight now. That's Ryan. Everything has a gender
Somewhere just got triggered
Okay, that's all right. I think I know
No
Go away go away shoosh shoosh. I
Think ah
Look at that. You got to always look
yeah, yeah, I
Don't think this is it
Whoa. Hey Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry shoosh sheesh
All right bringing you with me just for shielding Oh
God
Apparently, you're not supposed to click on big doors
Why don't you talk to no, okay, I think this is it I think I remember oh god
Damn this is confusing back in the day laboratory. Sorry, where are we going?
Refinery
Can it be solved yeah from the laboratory we get the acid or whatever
Okay, all right Alexa
Oh
My god
How is this game
Still to this day
Hey, how you doing buddy?
How is this game still to this day
Outclassing
Almost any horror game. I played in so long
Sorry
Because you know so many games developers were inspired by emotion
the lack of Chimney to property event
To properly event the fumes from my most recent experiment has taken its toll on the soul on many of my less stable
Ingredients in storage some seem unaffected but many are stained by the fumes and will be difficult to cyllage
I shall do what I can and move them to the wine cellar
So means we need to go to the wine so
Chemically angry happy mood from the laboratory to the wine cellar. Okay, so we need to
Wise things shaking
We need to get what we need and we need
alright relax
I should be more cooperate
So my third attempt to produce the artificial bit tire by day
The former compounds like the potency I need but I since I'm closed calamine and orbit-man
Are given and the cute cry it binds them well
But this time I will attempt aqua regia instead of aqua Fortis and hope it will produce a more even solution
What in the world the experiment was unsuccessful the solution is highly acid? Okay, so we need to make the answer
Let's make some acid brauch. Come on, perhaps one
Day I will return one day I will return if it wasn't for that thought of you my love
I wouldn't be able to go on when I find myself doing terrible things
I take comforting as long as I'm able to think of you and longed for a life together
I know I'm better than the others. I weep for them
They lust for power without restraint where I only crave for fair crave fair judgment. Is they in a safe return? Yeah. It's almost like
Oh
It's the water month dessert
He made it my accident didn't he
Oh
Sharks
So you hear that someone's upstairs walking on the wood where you came from how freaky is
Right
The simple things
Thinking about how different the horror game genre. I came after this with all the jump scares and the fire mags of
Finance of Freddy's
This is where the wine cellar is that doesn't make any sense
Hello flipping textures
Archives it's down here
I sported on so this is like our hub area
Let's check out our case
Ooh, I remember this place
Okay, alright next episode
We will
Investigate further. Yes
If you want another episode smash like
Would very much appreciate it. Maybe we can bring back the daily. Let's place for the sake of this
I think that could be really fun and any support you want to give I appreciate and if other than I'll see you guys tomorrow(Sub:MrDosa)
Check out merch everybody link in description. Bye(Sub:MrDosa)
Fucking teleporting stones(Sub:MrDosa)
Let's see oil. Oh I shouldn't use that(Sub:MrDosa)